crise sanitaire crise économique
chaque nation tentent de vivre survivre
à une pandémie dévastatrice
hier lors d'une réunion de la troisième
commission de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu spécialisée dans les droits
humains
l'ambassadeur de chine auprès des
nations unies s'est mué en porte parole
d'une fronde presque scientifique
nous saisissons cette occasion pour
appeler à la levée complète et immédiate
des mesures coercitives unilatérales
afin de permettre une réponse aux
qu'ovide 19 complète et efficace de tous
les membres de la communauté
internationale 26 signataires dans la
biélorussie la corée du nord neuf pays
africains ou encore les deux géants
chinois et russes 26 nations qui
s'adresse notamment aux états unis et
aux pays occidentaux
nous continuons d'assister à
l'application de mesures coercitives
unilatérales contraires aux buts et
principes de la charte des nations unies
et du droit international au
multilatéralisme et aux normes
fondamentales des relations
internationales un véritable pamphlet à
l'égard des grandes nations du monde
pour exemple les états unis ont
unilatéralement proclamé le 20 septembre
dernier le retour aux sanctions des
nations unies contre l'iran si les gens
veulent me dire la source des lacunes et
des problèmes du pays
l'adresse est à la maison blanche à
washington washington et ses dernières
trois années ils ont empêché à travers
des opérations terroristes l'achat des
médicaments et de nourriture
en imposant des sanctions injustes
illégales et inhumaines qui ont coûté au
pays au moins 150 milliards de dollars
une pression liée au nucléaire un
dossier sensible
il ya un an paris londres ou encore
berlin était également favorable au
maintien de sanctions adoptées en 2017
par l'onu à l'encontre de la corée du
nord pour lui faire arrêter ses
programmes d'armement nucléaire
la réélection controversée du président
biélorusse une nouvelle loi sécuritaire
hong kong en posées par la chine ou
encore le gouvernement vénézuélien de
nicolás maduro des dossiers chauds
certes mais aujourd'hui pékin
25 entre nations appelle plus que jamais
à une solidarité face à un virus des
plus mortels
la pandémie de kobe de 19 continue
d'affecter gravement toutes les nations
en particulier des pays en développement
la réponse au coït 19 et le
rétablissement des pays nécessite une
solidarité mondiale et une coopération
internationale est d'aider clarations
qui rejoignent celles de la haute
commissaire des nations unies aux droits
de l'homme
michelle bachelet favorable dès mars à
l'assouplissement aux suspensions de ces
sanctions
pour éviter l'effondrement de systèmes
de santé déjà fragile ces dernières
semaines les états unis et leurs alliés
européens ont affirmé que les sanctions
imposées ne concerne pas le domaine
humanitaire